[Music]
so if we go to keihan it's going to be
the same he's driving I take enough
deviation that I can load that
P got it there's a there's some
difference now because I'm not just
trying to move him in the sagittal plane
I'm trying to generate that front inward
kazushi okay so as I get into the center
I hit there and it's he starts to bounce
off that's when I turn back into the arm
cuz that's when the arm becomes
isolated you don't want to come into the
arm at the
start he he hits boom Center you get it
and then you continue this the spiral
don't go negative
and then attempt to push that that is
something different got it you know what
causes that what you let him go
completely by you and then you
push and to me the first Ed me is the
end of the technique because after that
requires a what if what if he keeps
pushing on the arm well then I come
around I keep attacking the arm okay so
deviate as much as your skills requir
hit the center and continue the
spiral into the
Emi if you projecting correctly you
don't get pinned when you're making him
go away from you so once he
deviates moving in do you see I can move
in right right
[Music]
away again it doesn't matter if you're
low it doesn't matter if you're high you
can touch the center from wherever
you're at high arm touch the
center low arm tou the center I can go
below the
[Music]
center got it